I would definitely didn't think of it as
a career that was literally just like
five seconds of bravery that changed my
life and I wanted it so badly and they
were like honestly you shouldn't come at
all anymore because I don't want to see
your family disappointed if you come
tomorrow there's not gonna be any room
for you to audition I honestly think you
should just go home and try again next
year
letting the core of who you are and kind
of letting all your walls down in front
of the world and in front of other
people is the greatest thing that you
could do need motivation watch a top ten
with belief nation what's up at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a woman who went
from dropping out of ninth grade in
school with dreams of becoming a singer
to having her first solo studio album
debut at number one on the Billboard
charts led by its lead single Havana
she's Camila Kibeho and here's my take
on her top ten rows of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one take a shot I initially was
not trying to do music at all I mean I
came to the United States my family came
and my parents made that choice my mom
came over to Miami and her main thing
was just like we don't have money to get
you into college so you're gonna have to
get a scholarship and you're gonna have
to study your butt off and so that was
always my main focus was just I was like
a book nerd that was just like studying
studying studying so I didn't really
think of it as a plausible thing even
though it was always my escape you know
I would always sneak off into my room
when my parents went to Walmart and I
would just like sing but yeah I would
definitely didn't think of it as a
career that was literally just like five
seconds of bravery that changed my life
where I decided to you know try out for
a show we asked Camila what do you want
for your quinceanera party and she told
me I want you to go with me to an
audition what do you do when you're not
singing
I would love to say something
interesting but all I do is sing karaoke
and watch like One Direction videos rule
number two my personal favorite be
persistent I went to the produce around
of The X Factor and after that they sent
you to perform for the actual judges and
so when they wrote me the letter
basically they said that I was a what's
that coffee
alternate write and alternate and
alternate which means that you're not
guaranteed a spot to audition in front
of the judges and if they have time at
the end of the show then you can
audition but that's never you still sit
there and wait wait wait so the
auditions were all the way in North
Carolina and so my whole family and I
traveled to North Carolina to see if
maybe I could audition so the auditions
the judges auditions are three days the
first day I get there and I'm
about to go on the stage and sing and I
have my microphone in my hand and a
producer comes and says sorry we don't
have enough time as you keep going
throughout the days your name keeps
going down and down on the list because
there's different alternates for every
day so anyway so that so then I said ok
like I'm just gonna try like to come the
next day so the next thing I come same
like same basically the same thing
happens and I'm a crying like backstage
and the producer like my grandma's there
that my grandma's crying cuz we were all
like this sucks like I'm not gonna get a
chance to audition and I wanted it so
badly and they were like honestly you
shouldn't come at all anymore because I
don't want to see your family
disappointed if you come tomorrow
there's not gonna be any room for you to
audition I honestly think you should
just go home and try again next year
yeah and so Simon Cowell luckily walks
out like behind the stage and I was like
you were a really tight white shirt yeah
and I was like I was like Simon they
won't let me audition could you please
let me audition Simon and all the judges
on the show they have no idea what the
alternate process is actually like they
just see people walk out on stage give
them a s whatever and so he was like oh
yeah for sure you can audition and I
turn it over to the executive producer
and I was like don't like C's he's Simon
Cowell and he's telling me I can't
addition contrastive I like yeah thanks
can I please just come back tomorrow and
so basically to sum up the story they
saw how persistent I was and how much I
wanted to be there because I ended up
like just crying that producer I'm being
like honestly I don't even have to you
don't even have to put me as an
alternate tomorrow I just want to be in
the building to know that I did that I
did everything that I could to know that
if there maybe is a 1% chance that I'm
allowed to audition that I'm here that
I'm still here for it and so they saw
how persistent I was and the next
ended up letting me audition rule number
three find true success
probably one fifth Harmony's so this
merger next back when the show takes off
and you guys it's a group you know
better together reflection yeah did you
feel like you made it was this feeling
of accomplishment like what were you
going through as the group started to
take off and you're part of that it felt
really great from a level of man we've
worked so hard our families have
sacrificed so much but I definitely felt
like I work from home became like a
really big song there when you know
songs about her started to get played I
wanted to like feel more what I heard on
the radio if that makes sense
I learned so much I'm so so grateful for
that whole experience I don't even think
that I would have felt like that
yearning to even start writing to
express myself they weren't for the fact
that you know I was singing songs that I
didn't really connect to but I did a
song with Shana and as I did I know we
did last time and that song was not
nearly as successful as work from home
if it came on and the radio I was like
whoa like this is about something that
happened to me like you know what I mean
and even though it wasn't as successful
it just I just felt more rule number
four is be yourself I think for me just
being yourself and kind of letting the
core of who you are and kind of letting
all your walls down in front of the
world and in front of other people is
the greatest thing that you could do
that's also what I try to do with my
music as well as just be as honest as
possible
and just kind of share the vulnerable
parts of myself because I think that
that's very relieving when you can do
that because then you're just yourself
you don't have to try to be anything
else
rule number five push yourself I have a
lot of moments where I'm like shy and I
don't want to be you know I want to be
like away from people but I think
challenges always make me have to step
it up and so I push I push myself a lot
you know life begins outside of your
comfort zone and you know sometimes it's
good to push yourself and do the
unexpected and you never know what you
might find rule number six be consumed
by passion I just feel like advice that
I would that I would give it's just like
let yourself be so consumed in in your
art or whatever your passion is it's
literally the greatest feeling in the
world it's like love like it's you know
to just let yourself be just like
swallowed whole by what makes you feel
alive and what connects you to you know
the universe and that inner voice it
there's nothing more more beautiful than
that and it's such a it's such a
selfless thing to share that you know to
share that with the world because I
think I love that there's and there's
this quote I can't remember it word for
word but this guy says something like
share your share your talent and share
your dreams with the world because what
the world needs is more people who come
alive something something along those
lines but yeah because you know by you
just expressing yourself
you kind of ignite you can you know
ignite a fire in somebody else to
express them so in some way you know
like and that was dressing here so I
would just make us all like so much
happier as people you know what I mean
like just do everything do everything
for love and you'll you'll feel so
fulfilled rule number seven start small
oh yes - Graham you posted about writing
music in the hotel room that is totally
100% you I would get instrumentals from
songs that already existed so I have
these demos where you hear like the
music is from like born to die by Lana
Del Ray and I wrote like a whole other
song over it and that's how I basically
started to develop my voice as a
songwriter when I got into the studio -
really for the first time to work on
this album which was January everybody
was kind of they came in with his eyes
were like oh I have an idea for you like
play it for me and I was
let's do something from scratch and they
were like oh you actually write like you
actually have a point of view you
actually have something that you want to
talk about today like I'm so happy that
I thought I started writing those like
demos on the road because if it weren't
for that I wouldn't have even had the
confidence to be like oh I I want to do
this today guys and as opposed to just
taking something but I wouldn't have
even know where to start
rule number eight express emotions I'm
just trying to connect with my heart and
with my soul and kind of bare my soul to
people I feel like that's kind of my my
goal as an artist whether it's in my
music or you know in a photo shoot I
want to make sure that I'm able to bring
out my emotions whatever it is that I'm
feeling when I go into the studio I want
to write about the scary places in my
heart I want to write about the feelings
that art can be kind of sad and
uncomfortable like the real human parts
of us when I was younger I would have
never imagined that I could be able to
do this for a living like music was
always something that I'd love to do and
it was my form of escape I hopefully can
create that form of escapism for other
people when they asked them to my music
so that's kind of what I'm what I'm
trying to create rule number nine is
expect the worst what is that feeling
for you that there that that's solo
debut it's uh it's intense hearts racing
hands shakin my mom has always told me
when you make your when I made that
decision she was like just you know
don't expect anything like expect expect
the worst and you know if you still
obviously still want to do this then go
ahead and do it and you know I really
did expect the worst I was like you know
what if nobody cares if you know my
first album flops all my songs flop I
don't care I'm still gonna do this
because I want to do this for me and so
I was perfectly ready for none of it to
happen and I you know so it's the fact
that you know people connected to Havana
and that people are connecting to never
be the same and people are just
connecting to my music is super it's
like the best feeling ever
and rule number ten the last one before
the bonus clips have fun the discussion
is from Michelle she
wants to know if you can like rap from
the songs bad things rap a few lines is
that bad hey if it feels good you come
back like I knew you would hurt
we're both Wow I love you say wow wow
wow like we're both wild dream now
scratching my back dude some kind of bad
things the remix
now I've got some special Camilla bonus
clips for you but before that my
question of the day is around her rule
number nine expect the worst
do you expect the worst do you expect
the best what's better or worse I want
to know leave it down the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clips
having your mom travel with you and be
here today and that is the second time
I've met your mom the second time I met
you really face to face so I know she's
with you all the time
yeah that's obviously when you were
growing up a huge part of your
upbringing was you can be as talented as
you want but at the end of the day
unless you make an impression on people
that is positive then you're setting
yourself up to fail yeah I mean for sure
and I feel like it's not even thinking
about that with that intention because I
feel like you can't just be nice because
you know you don't want to fail you want
people to like you I feel like she's
just always taught me that more
important than anything than being
talented then being you know all these
qualities that are great being brave
being smart being talented you know
being you know working yeah all of that
stuff nothing is as important as being
kind like I think being kind is the most
important thing you can be and she's
always you know told me that's the most
important thing in people period no
matter who they are raise your standard
cool it's core value passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on Europe
it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details